yeah preparing that's one point it come
in the Canadian Canadian moose this
business comes to life sir and attacks
me at some point you really yeah he
shouldn't need a jerky
he's from Halifax good boy but we have a
we have a policy in here where where
Kurt arts dad played by Mel Gibson is
enticing Dylan our shared son with
buying a gun I gotta go so we have a we
have a whole discussion Wow and Brad and
I are trying to be great Co parents
we're trying to show that we're on a
united front but there is a part of me
who would like to see my son experienced
from a wildlife action but I have to do
the right thing brand I have a deal and
I'm making sure that my dad doesn't come
between the two of us yeah talk about
the dads you got John let's go and you
got Mel Gibson which one would you say
is more like your type of dads the one
you would want to raise you almost let
Kalin he's just such a sweet gentle man
and Mel's playing a guy was pretty
aggressive and pretty out there but it's
all in fun so I kick off I would like
John for a short time John's character
though is Don is not afraid of telling a
very long story that's the only problem
so if I'm with that dad yeah maybe be
annoying you could work a lot together I
mean this is your third film together we
can hear that rely for what's going on
definite for like a third time I love
this man whatever good do you love about
Martin it's so special about it was so
special
that's a good luck I mean right here
we have a very similar physique I'm just
quitting this sweater gunawan I don't
want to embarrass him with my with my
arms was ripping strong done any loan
than me I'm very much sweet and hard
hard you're watching a little better
your emotions are lower emotionally a
little hard work I don't admire some of
those uh largemouth bass over there yes
we were we were your big yeah they are
you get another big guy coming on John
Cena Yeah right who has bigger biceps
well there's there's just no comparison
John Cena like he ate that buffalo air
yeah moose let's go these places are the
size of my thighs and you said there's a
wrestling scene in this movie choose but
is it between John Cena and you you have
to see you have to see when I put the
smackdown and just Mac down John was too
afraid to wrestle either one of us
really yeah so actually all his whole
persona is an act yeah it's actually
losing 90 pounds to play this part we're
going to see a thin mean fiery yes
Johnny John Cena